poverty is a hallmark of istanbul's
Kurdish quarter there are hardly any
jobs and very few perspectives for the
future either the streets are full of
the Kurdish hdb party's election slogans
but since they entered Parliament for
the first time in the last election
problems with Turkish nationalists have
grown the Nationalists resent Kurds like
this grocery store owner and an
atmosphere of fear is spreading through
the Kurdish quarter public use unless I
can use that said of course we Kurds
don't feel safe anymore I know some
shops have been attacked not my own but
I've heard about them I'm wary I hope it
doesn't stay like this hopefully
there'll be peace again soon we have no
problems between Turks and Kurds for a
long time but since the conflict has
flared up again I've been getting really
worried and chillin you so where is
turkey heading that's a question on the
minds of many younger Turks these days
who are generally more western-oriented
the government has been supporting
startups in recent years it runs special
programs to help budding entrepreneurs
access venture capital but political
stability is just as important to the
new companies you're building
partnerships and all the companies
somehow are interested in where you're
located and how we are doing the
business and this will also affect the
way they are doing business so they need
to be also at the partner with a stable
company so being a stable company means
a being a stable country stability would
also attract more of the economically
important tourists like two years ago we
had all these protests going on at the
gezi Park so it affected almost fifty
five percent of all the entire
reservations coming to Turkey we had so
many cancellations by the time
I really never want to experience the
same thing again the head of one
government startup assistance program
hopes things will calm down after the
elections sure we are not happy to see
such a most bearing in our country but
it's it's not a problem at all because
we know that there will be a solution
soon the Turkish economy can only
succeed if the government ensures stable
conditions for it to thrive in Sunday's
election gives the country another
chance to make a fresh start